[Applaudissements]
la fête avec michel fabre ont alors
rapidement plaisante mais après 50 ans
de carrière
on se dit qu'il peut tout animé bien sûr
muriel bricaire et j'aimerais qu'on le
vérifie ici en direct je suis sur vous
pour y animer sur un petit venez avec
moi
venez michel confie ma petite chérie
aller à lisbonne et michel était le
petit adjoint jean michel gaillard tv et
ses parties à l'ets michel drucker sur
m6 web chez grosbill ou bien celle ci me
suis-je michel aux platines ce soir de
la bible on veut redonner le dernier 55
fait péter la sono dans la zone mais les
graves qui fait spéciale dédicace à tous
les poteaux parti trop courtes mieux
band aura écouté ce sont les tabacs
comme ça envoie du lourd
[Applaudissements]